Germany's Russian affairs coordinator is
going against the grain in reaching out
to both politicians and the business
world in a country that has been
isolated by the West officially
President Putin is a persona non grata
he was conspicuously absent from The
Hague summit earlier this week and his
foreign minister was not invited to stay
the g8 has been reduced to the g7 longer
in the absence of a political
environment that would accommodate the
g8 there is no g8 Gupta neither as a
summit nor a format gifu concrete and
Gibson naw its format gay not Ella has
warned against the decision and is
working behind the scenes to keep the
lines of communication open even with
the government in Moscow if been a
foolish pizzarriba does naturally I'm
concerned that formats which encouraged
communication are now no more I'm trying
to send a different signal to show that
we are still willing to talk and that we
want contact and i can tell you i did
not struggle to fill my schedule here
environmental gum floats of Martin some
refer to Ella and his ilk as Russia
sympathizers others cut to the chase
called them wimps and demand a tough
stance against Putin President Obama
also says the Russian president should
be punished for his audacious annexation
of Crimea
the Russian national anthem sounds at
every occasion even in schools across
the former ukrainian Peninsula Russian
flags are put up as a mark of Putin's
apparent success many say the strong
military presence is reminiscent of the
Cold War as is the power divided but the
Russian president seems unconcerned
fuzzy yet stylish tub the Russians have
managed to strengthen NATO which is the
exact opposite of what they wanted we
are now unexpectedly faced with what
feels like a psychological threat from
the east and are seeing liberal people
in Sweden suddenly saying they haven't
done enough for defense and should be
thinking about closer relations with
NATO that is the result of Putin's
politics under the sisters again mr.
politique from pootie Russia's real
power is not men in uniform but in the
gas that flows through these pipes the
German economy benefits from it and as
it pains to preserve business ties the
head of Siemens unashamedly met with
Vladimir Putin thereby counterbalancing
Germany's foreign policy yes she
wouldn't budge see our problem you said
Zeman's and Russia are bound by a 160
year partnership and this long tradition
between our company and Russia also
shows that when faced with challenges
it's better to speak to each other then
about each other now the talk is of
sanctions Europe is threatening to
restrict trade with Russia if Putin
tries to annex any more of Ukraine but
Moscow could stop gas supplies in
response alhasan ones though we're not
going to allow ourselves to be
blackmailed there is enough gas and oil
on the world market major suppliers such
as Iran in Iraq are in the process of
expanding and America and Canada will be
exporting gas in huge quantities so I'm
not worried his organ in Moscow dare not
error and others in his circle are going
for a non-confrontational approach they
call it change through trade
ya havin I would a foul our energy
cooperation with Russia is good the fact
is it survived the entire Cold War
including the worst crises whether Cuba
or Berlin our bilateral relations have
always been reliable and we want things
to continue in the same way valletta
elevates you here again we avoid a vital
matter good trade relations have served
to protect against crises the hope is
that the current conflict will not prove
an exception